[Musique]
désir
harry mon biquet
[Musique]
depuis quelques temps vous pouvez vous
laisser aller à tous vos fantasmes avec
le téléphone rose
osez le sexe par téléphone 200 francs la
minute
à nos désirs harriman biquet elle fait
ce désir et tu as eva la plus coquine à
plus sensuelle de toutes les réponses 2
on peut dire que tu es bien tomber toi
ils valent bata plaisir quel type de
femme
grande blonde est plutôt chargé seront
perdus à 1115 où on touche
correspondante et honda stu peut pas
savoir
amat 72 80 à 60 96 les cheveux couleur
soleil d'or bouchard mourir tu vois quoi
une belle bouche mais si j'avais une
belle bouche sur génial gauche c'est ce
que je suis en train de faire tout de
suite c'est parce que j'aimerais que tu
as bossé mais vous n'en n'ont pas tu
vois pas tout ne va pas en train de
manger ton petit corps ou une tombe
picard on le sent bien que ça chouette
hein mais bon mon petit à petit pour
être vraiment vous dis moi mon week-end
au stade de la conversation là on en a
mis ça t'en prends tu veux poursuivre on
harel comme tu veux euh je préfère vous
appelez le mois prochain madame eva
battant brest le combat oui d'accord
c'est un peu cher mais alors quel
érotisme
[Musique]